cowboy bebop is such a popular anime
that has broken out of the anime bubble
and made its way into the zeitgeist so
popular in foundational attacks is a
late 90s anime that is frequently
recommended as a good starting place for
newcomers to the anime genre basically
if you had to sum up cowboy bebop it's
the animated version of the joss whedon
sci-fi series firefly before firefly
became a thing debuting in 1998 the
anime show follows a group of space
cowboys skirting the law and struggling
to survive in a spaceship whose name
also happens to be you guessed it cowboy
bebop the protagonist of this tale is
spike spiegel a caller's ice bounty
hunter with a dark past who rarely shuns
the opportunity to make his work fun
joining spike on these intergalactic
bounty hunts is his close friend jet
black as well as faye valentine ed and
an adorable dog named ein there are
action-packed fight sequences and
romantic subplots galore so it's got a
little something for everybody it's easy
to see why the show was so popular even
if it only lasted for one season the
original anime was so popular that it
eventually got its own live-action
reboot on netflix the project was
originally announced at variety in 2017
then in 2019 that same outlet reported
the project had cast john cho who
started for shakir and daniela pineda to
play spike jet and fave respectively
cowboy bebop finally debuted in november
after releasing more than one exciting
trailer to get audiences excited but it
wasn't enough because this week netflix
just made a major decision about season
2 that die hard fans of the show are
going to be sad to hear in early
december the hollywood reporter reported
the exclusive news that after just one
season netflix has chosen to cancel the
live-action cowboy bebop adaptation the
streaming platform was swift in its
decision opting to cut the project to
loose following its november 19th
release according to the outlets the
cancellation of cowboy bebop is likely
due to some degree to the low ratings on
rotten tomatoes the series currently
holds a 46 critic score and a 56 average
audience score among the negative
reviews of the show time magazine
remarks it misses the core appeal of
cowboy bebop which finds its deepest
resonance in a richly textured surface
the new york times was particularly
tough on the show noting in its resolute
ordinary nurse the main value of this
new bebop would be to drive you back to
watch the old one the cider's review
echoes these sentiments stating at one
point cowboy bebop isn't cringingly bad
but it's also not particularly memorable
either but the hollywood reports is
reporting it was also noted that on
netflix's top 10 site cowboy bebop
accrued more than 74 million viewing
hours globally in the days following its
mid-november premiere however this
didn't last long as there was a reported
59 drop in viewing hours between late
november and early december a
disappointing turn to be sure it was
however noted that the streaming giants
quote takes pride in gambling as it did
with a live-action adaptation of cowboy
bebop a final nail in the coffin here is
likely the production costs to bring the
anime world of cowboy bebop to life in a
live-action setting although there is no
official reporting on how much it cost
to make the show it's evident that
efforts were made to make every far set
of the show closely resemble the 90s
anime so far social media reactions for
the cancellation have largely been mixed
on twitter one user wasn't exactly
dismayed to hear the news claiming that
the show lacked quote the spirit of the
original another twitter user thought
that the series wasn't all bad but it
ultimately failed to justify itself and
one person implored netflix to
reconsider the decision writing i was
looking forward to seeing where it went
bummed there are plenty of sad fans out
there including some who think the move
was in part because of a vocal minority
of quote the social media hey brigade
complaining about it one commenter on
twitter weighed in saying that while
they liked the actors and the plot the
title was not working for them they went
on to suggest maybe if it had a
different name more people would have
given it a shot additionally the cast of
cowboy bebop shared their reactions to
the sad news john cho puts up a very
colourful post on twitter using a gif of
tom selleck saying i'm okay while
appearing to be not quite okay to
explain his feelings mustafa shakir also
opted to post a comment on twitter
without directly addressing the news the
jet black actor posted a tweet that said
see you space cowboys and added some
emojis and a gif from the cowboy bebop
anime as a farewell to the show on
instagram daniela pineda shared a photo
of a celebratory toast going horribly
wrong captioning the photo with a simple
uh at the end of the day reboots and
remakes will never go out of style so
there's always a chance cowboy bebop
could be redone or picked up by another
network
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]